[Music]  i feel free  still to come on darcy and stacy we're  in turkey we're heading to istanbul for  our transformational journey out with  the old and end with the new i feel like  i'm in la la land i'm talking different  i'm smelling different tasting different  i'm loving it yay  i love it oh it looks so much good this  is the biggest pageant in connecticut  and i think it's a way of bringing out  our most confident self looks like  you're tired and hungry if you want that  crown get your head in the game  i'm meeting with someone who lately  caused me hard time  so  octavia oh god  you tried to make me look someone who  i'm not calm that damn let me tell you  something i'm not darcy so you're not  gonna talk slick and smart to me  well there's something i wanted to tell  you  what i went to the doctors and he said i  have a cyst on my ovary  cancer  [Music]  i it was a  doctor  he can't do that to me anymore  georgie  good to see you  hi jesse  [Music]